what is going on there citizens of the
reject nation we are going to watch
today she-hulk episode 3 easter eggs and
breakdown from new rockstars but before
we go into any of that one thing i
really do got to mention
is
john's feelings
how are you feeling i feel so uh
attended to right now i feel very held
good how do you feel what are your
emotions doing today it doesn't matter
it does to me but we're not gonna talk
about it like let's just watch this
[Music]
welcome back to new rockstars i'm
jessica clements and i'm so pumped to
talk to you about the third episode
because there's so many fun things that
happened we got wong bean just won long
just long and more new characters to
learn from and as always she hulk coming
into herself plus megan
the mother effin stallion it's like
jessica jessica clemens of new rockstars
we have an episode for you and i said
bless up baby now let's get into our
episode three breakdown jen is storming
the dodc like she's been there a hundred
times as she walks through the lasers i
noticed the a113 on the wall and
immediately went to a113 pixar number if
you don't know it's the classic number
used by a ton of pixar alumni at the
california institute of the arts and
it's hidden in a ton of pixar oh really
homecoming avengers end game guardians
of the galaxy so it's not just an
animation pixar's canon videos and
images on a milk prison walls which i
think is pretty insane and futuristic
but they do this almost in every marvel
movie so it's not too new emil discloses
pretty late i might add that wong forced
him out of prison and he knew wong's
complete title probably because wong's
been introducing himself as the sorcerer
supreme since no way home and i still am
right damn right respect on wong's name
account nicki and juan's mutual
connection is bruce i love this
confirmation that avengers can have
linkedin accounts because i'm sure tony
had one he's so proud to be the sorcerer
supreme he also marked full-time
librarian at carmitage for 11 years and
a target sales associate for nine years
so if my math is correct give or take
because we all know no one updates their
linkedin maybe just me wong was
appointed sorcerer supreme in 2018
following the blip 11 years before that
as a librarian so that's 2007. but for
nine years he was a target sales
associate so from 1998 to approximately
2007 wong was training at carmitage but
also side gigged as a target employee go
off king wait a minute where is wong
from originally have we established that
in the mcu i'm very much well aware that
target can exist
in other parts of this world global
capitalism i do not have that confirmed
i have not researched that wong should
have a little bit of an understanding of
the u.s legal system if the target he
worked at was right here in the united
states of goddamn america but it wasn't
it was in nepal are you sure are you
sure are you sure yeah it says it on the
thing it was incompetent why didn't you
cut me off earlier i didn't know that's
where you were headed
i don't read
well that's why jess is here to read it
for us you're right it says it that's an
embarrassing thing i literally
contributed nothing and i contributed
back on track jen breaks the fourth wall
and here we hear a little transitional
twinkle before it
i know you can't wait to see long i get
it which we haven't really heard yet
it's hard to describe but it's a sort of
futuristic synthy wave passing between
your left and right speakers it's
similar to the noise tony's machine
model makes an end game when it was a
successful run it seems like jen knows
it's the wcu also known as the wang
cinematic universe because she wants us
to remember this show isn't about him or
bruce or blonsky it's she-hulk baby also
jen if that ain't a self-driving car
keep your hands and two we get the pass
by effect introducing news los angeles
now announcing jennifer walters is
representing emil blonsky he used the
photos straight out of 2008's incredible
hulk below the headline reads super
powered influencer titania speaks out
about latest legal troubles confident
her legal team will make it go away
which shows that her altercation with
jen has not smoothed over in the
slightest we see the tattle news frame
like e entertainment news an anchor
played by amanda solis who also is the
entertainment anchor for good day la and
another
wondering if they were real that's how
popular she-hulk is right now on what i
assume is youtube she's covered under
the tag she-hulk news and superhero
she's being talked about on despiata
daily news there's theory videos on
she-hulk not being real a hoax
conspiracy theories on this poor woman
dear lord is this how i sound all the
time i hope not they've also already
started calling her the big green woman
on the internet this girl has gone viral
if you want to call being called a big
green woman viral yeah i would i'll
quickly explain the ups and downs of all
she-hulk's online threads first we get a
nonsensical man i made that up played by
rory asplin who was featured in episode
one of she-hulk as a stunt performer i
think he might have been the guard on
the right we get mixed sexist comments
from people like dom the bounty hunter
hard seltzer steve and darby don't care
tick tocks emojis memes more unwanted
male commentary and i'm about to hulk
out just reading and listening to them
all do you think they inserted those in
the actual screenplay or do you think
they did it like in post you know how
they're always like backed up on their
vfx and stuff
do you think that with the discourse
that was coming out surrounding this
like obviously they had an awareness
that ship was gonna pop off with a
certain part of the online community
obviously but i kind of get the inkling
that perhaps they decided to insert that
in the middle of being late to getting
some of their [ __ ] done i bet they had
some kind of template scene and probably
some basic tweets or whatever written
out but then yeah once the show actually
started to premiere and you got the big
wave of people's reactions especially
the negative ones i bet they pulled
those right out of actual comment
threads pushing agendas that's right by
putting on display what people actually
say
breaking the fourth wall for real she's
being covered on the news the
conversation with jefferson coop we meet
blonsky's former attorney gideon wilson
played by jason turner who hey we didn't
see in the incredible hulk or anything
else and b is sam wilson's brother in
the comics gideon first appears in world
war hulk gamma corpse number one he was
sam and sarah's older brother when he
joined the gamma corps they were
basically made to take down the hulk he
was super supportive of his brother
becoming captain america but gideon's
story in the comics is super rough his
son died from aids and he took his anger
basically out on the whole it's pretty
sad but
it's a it's a good comics it's good
comic run and we're never going to see
that in the in live action no that's
gonna be the whole uh you know new world
order is just about sam dealing with
this funeral for his actually it would
be pretty cool if he does show up in new
world order and you're like i've seen
this guy before yeah
oh [ __ ] he was in jail for like a second
yeah and now he's way more buff but in
mcu he doesn't really exist that we know
of to sam and sarah's knowledge it was
just the two of them but maybe gideon as
the oldest left far before sam and sarah
could remember there's a lot of theories
that could be made but i think it's
important to note that they chose gideon
wilson as the character to prosecute
abomination in the past rather than
anyone else we're introduced to mallory
book officially played by renee ellis
goldsberry if you remember this is the
woman from hamilton who's an amazing
singer but also a phenomenal actress
just a reminder in the comics she was an
amazing lawyer but just a rival to jen
and superman i didn't really like her
it's revealed she becomes a friend of
mine shapeshifter who made himself look
like megan the stallion and jen does my
job breaking it down who she is so i
don't have to sorry you thought you were
dating megan the stallion
a multiple grammy award winner mega star
megan the sound what part of shape
shifter did you not get
you thought she drove up a sub more
specifically a shape-shifting light elf
named roona from new asgard who we later
found out is the daughter of an elven
diplomat of asgard and now new asgard
the light elves have been pretty good to
most knowledge they're native to alphine
one of the nine realms conquered by odin
wong appears behind him like a living
room there's a couch coffee table some
chairs and nice lights it's a mood
sitting room it's probably a combination
and guess where he got all that
furniture from
he stole it on his last day of work
that's what he did people do you think
he was able to wear his red robes to
target they kind of just let you wear
whatever red they want no man target's a
really serious place i'm not even joking
sorry target employees are
well they're all dicks i'm really sorry
i've had target employees recognize me
before i gotta say
i am not a fan
hey hey don't you make youtube videos
cats out the bag wong forced abomination
out of prison because he needed a worthy
opponent to train to be the sorcerer
supreme wong mentioned that he's aware
of the spell that wiped everyone's
memory of knowing peter parker because
doctor strange basically had to ask him
permission to do it if you remember
after acknowledging wong left saying
just leave me out of this he also adds
it's very messy which could refer to all
those unanswered questions people have
about it juan goes on to share some
advice saying wait a minute
am i having the right thought here who
remembers everyone's memories being
erased yes i thought part of the spell
was no one's supposed to remember wasn't
supposed to remember because he didn't
cast that spell doctor strange cast that
spell yeah maybe doctor strange filled
him in later or maybe doctor strange
remembers then
that's fair because yeah he's not
supposed to remember either
or was
that's a great question
did wang go to some kind of immunity
place where he could be free from the
effects or or was he added into the
spell somehow juan goes on to share some
advice saying we'll send him to the
mirror dimension the parallel dimension
that allowed people to practice magic
and fight you remember in doctor strange
then offering the shadow dimension which
i don't think is the shadow realm
necessarily but he meant the dark
dimension where we last saw cleo and
doctor strange headed to and multiverse
and madness we get a shot of pug's
laptop he has you screen aka youtube up
we're watching the meg and the stallion
and popularity three songs
on the right videos like pony imposter
thinks it's the style these are real
shoes three honest reviews i really want
to click on it
a short film written and directed by
kevin rodingen who does vfx for she-hulk
series kevin i'm sorry for butchering
your name but i'm still going to respect
you here's his photo and my favorite
bear fight dude you got a weird
algorithm
what are you watching are you getting
recommended iron man 3 honest review and
then a bear attack and iron man 3 exists
in the george is that the review of the
shoes because they made like they're in
universe iron man shoes but they're also
like iron man yeah iron man threes like
jordan ah that's clever and there is a
real that's clever line of iron man
shoes in our reality as well oh that is
so clever so pug just likes a good
sneaker he's a sneaker head you know
john you read well thanks
once pug recognizes it's runa and not
dennis we get the jaws like zoom in it's
so funny to me maybe because while he's
quiet dennis thinks it's because he has
a tesla cyber truck you know those like
super ugly cars that tesla made
we're back to the
prison the same red lasers that jen has
to walk through to see emil are outside
were with knbs news the anchor is played
by real life journalist sharon reed the
man with k-a-j-e-3
asked jen if it's true she's been
rejected by the avengers and in the show
we know that's a blatant lie even in the
comics she's left in return a ton of
times but has never been rejected by
them she's been fired yes but that's a
different kind of rejection if you know
what i mean we meet the soul mates and
boy was i right blair ruth marta sheila
alejandra yvonne and nicolette his
better writes blonsky plans on making a
meditation retreat on his plot of land
which possible spoilers i'm so sorry i
think we saw in the trailers already at
what i assumed was therapy oh yeah good
catch industry program guy sean holt
played by brooke brown the prison
counselor amy chance played by jennifer
van horn and the crying guard carl
cowart played by robert stevens wayne
now according to jen's documents they
don't match what was assigned in the
credits this could just be a little
mistake in post or jen genuinely
confused with their job i think it's the
first one which is no biggie i just have
to acknowledge it and in fact this part
you were like i don't know what a shiv
is it's a shank which i keep in my sock
at all times
if someone doesn't know what a ship is i
have to explain this
have you ever heard of a comet
insinuating it might be a little longer
until a mill truly gets his verdict but
also the coomatay covers a lot of things
it's one of the three main sections of
karate training it's not justin
bloodsport or that one episode of the
boondocks when we switch to our b story
we get a better look at judge price
played by george bryant and roona's
lawyer lauren jesper played by ruth
kaufman when this is said by judge price
she may have diplomatic immunity in new
asgard but we are not in new ascot it's
a tricky answer mainly because i'm not a
lawyer but according to the united
nations treaty collection modern
diplomat immunity was codified as
international law and the vienna
convention on diplomatic relations which
has been ratified by the u.s and norway
which is home to new asgard so basically
we agreed in article 9 that we the us
can consider someone as unwelcome but we
still have to let their home state know
if we don't hear back in a certain
period of time or they refuse we can ask
them to leave the u.s or we can cancel
the diplomats visa and bar them and
their families from returning to united
states ever again see my
issue that i kind of have with some of
the courtroom scenes like oh come on do
some more like in universe legal law
stuff of what is it like for the
superhero world to mesh with you know
the the old constitution rules and the
modern day government of the united
states that like really mix with our
real world and then dive into the
conversations of wait a minute though
can we consider new basically everything
that you just did
is like a kind of argument and debate
that i want the show to have yeah like
actually pull some real law make it
clear you did some legal research and
maybe enlighten us a little bit on the
inner workings of our society like
that's a fascinating conversation to
have and that's one there's
conversations like that that i kind of
want to be infused in the she-hulk show
which i don't think feel like they're
actually that interested in doing yeah
here's hoping the second half of the
show so when judge price said that he
could be referring to the fact that new
asgard is its own country within norway
and has different diplomatic immunity or
maybe because runa has it in new asgard
does it mean the us gave it to her to be
fair new asgard isn't that old and i
don't know how the un handles previously
signed treaties with new cities within
old countries but i'd assume they'd fall
under norway's jurisdiction if you're a
lawyer just hit me up or if you have
better knowledge of international law
just stand up please in the chat
where does this be which i think we all
remember from thor ragnarok and it's
perfect timing excuse me your honor but
asgard is not a place it is a people
therefore thor's inspirational speeches
are not admissible in court
there's god is not a place
it's a people
emile turns into abomination and he is
just so gentle picking up his shoes as
we know this abomination favors more to
the comics hence his little gilly gills
what i really hate though in this scene
is how much his partner swoon over him
changing into abomination it just makes
me want to throw myself out of a moving
car you know it's just like
why and then he's waving at them in the
reflection it's so
ugh i don't want to yuck anyone's young
but it's weird true so currently wong is
a wanted man a criminal for helping
facilitate a prisoner escape let's keep
that noted because wang is now a wanted
man the knbs news 6 reporter mentions
this is there any truth to the rumors
you got your powers from a mafia had
gone wrong
comics crime boss nicholas trask crew
shot and seriously injured jen
warranting a blood transfusion from
bruce giving her her abilities in the
back we see kcav 35 which we haven't
seen in the mcu but is the news station
for breaking bad i'm no way what
cannon that's my new favorite easter egg
dude maybe she'll have to argue against
saul goodman at some point that's an
amazing i love that
is that a real news station though like
they're in albuquerque
yeah yeah it's a bit of a weird pull but
at the same time who knows maybe it's
just somebody paying tribute maybe they
knew we're gonna have these episodes up
when uh better call saul is ending so we
can nod to the breaking bad universe
yeah that is awesome oh god yes and any
better call saul let me tell you what
happens
the app on nikki's phone is snafu which
is a satirical comic book from the 1950s
marvel comics made it to mimic mad
magazine written by stan lee catch here
when jem breaks the fourth wall these
duo don't notice but hulk noticed in the
first episode so maybe it's like the
family shared dna can recognize it
another anecdote we can see more kept
wondering about but worth noting as the
idea that only certain folks can see it
seeing as you can get up to three years
in jail or in prison for false
impersonation in california 60 days is a
great punishment but again not a lawyer
please don't use me as a cause to any of
your crimes people i would freak out i
screamed
so loud when megan the stallion
presented herself in that whole church
pete get up and fandom match that person
next to her is just as shook as i am
signature
included
so when dennis mentioned making sure
roona could never trick anyone again
with her powers it was right on the nose
that jen would think about using the
inhibitor remember bruce had it in the
first episode now this tricky tricky
instrument could open the door to the
mutant registration act we saw in x-men
seeing as we're already acknowledging
mutants exist in the mcu basically the
immune registration act identified and
tracked all mutants but could set up any
vigilante to target registered mutants
regardless capturing people and using an
inhibitor immediately sounds like a fine
idea until someone is falsely prosecuted
wrongfully imprisoned or killed while
holding it's not as easy as jen thinks
and this could set up shop for a very
dangerous game it's crazy how the shows
have been setting up x-men more than
than any of the movies
i thought she was saying she was trying
to get rid of her powers like x-men 3
the last hand yeah the best one in the
series
on citizen news tonight the news anchor
is played by bob dycastro who is also on
fox 11 la i just got to say it's kind of
crazy when you could be a news anchor
and then also be a paid actor at the
same time how am i supposed to trust you
under these false pretenses huh yeah and
how am i supposed to know that you're
not going to just try and get more and
more of these opportunities because they
likely pay better than being a new
banker yeah man just make your news more
and more sensational get more and more
on camera roles can't trust it can't
trust it man fake fake news all around
she finally interviews and it's a giant
step for she-hulk and i'm so proud no
pun intended i just love her and i'm
glad at how she's doing in the show when
young gets home she gets jumped by this
man in a yellow helmet and this guy who
has purple emitting glow from his gloves
and this guy with a blue emitting
crowbar and this man at the end has a
pinkish ball and chain we later find out
that one of the men is named thunderball
and oh baby wait till you get a gander
at this crew now you might have seen
them in avengers the earth mightiest
heroes fighting thor or an ultimate
spider-man but they are the super
villain team known as the wrecking crew
babies on their shirts why do they have
shirts for their crimes their story oh
they do have a symbol i didn't notice
that the weight aka the wrecker broke
into loki's home for the crowbar and
right as loki was getting powers from
carnella dirk got in the way and got it
he later fought thor and his powers
transferred from him to his crowbar but
in prison he met ex-physicist elliot
franklin aka thunderball brian koleski
aka piledriver and ex-army sergeant
henry camp aka bulldozer when they broke
free they retrieved the magical crowbar
they really stood in the lightning storm
pulled a shazam and each got a piece of
its power they each have distinct
weapons they use so bulldozer has his
armored helmet neck shoulder covers
wrecker has his crowbar thunderball has
a ball and chain and piledriver has huge
hands that are super strong they fought
in secret wars thunderball white guys
criminal syndicate during the scroll
invasion so ultimately we could see more
of them since we're headed in that
direction already but they did steal
these weapons from an asgardian
construction worker so maybe the origins
may change a little their backstory and
she-hulk could also be different from
the comics but these characters in the
comics are around all the time fighting
everyone and usually losing
for the real question who's their boss
and here's my theories in the comics
they've worked under the hood who we
know is coming into ironheart and they
worked under baron zemo who led the
masters of evil and fought the
thunderbolts so those two characters are
two big deals because they're getting
them in another series of movie anyways
the leader from incredible hulk he was
super excited to work with banner and
with his blood he could do a lot maybe
getting she-hulk would be even easier
that would be so cool if they brought
him back that would be awesome because
they had such a major setup with him and
nothing became of it well yeah and it
would very much fit in with the recent
run of just like going back into the
archives and legitimizing old things and
for that movie's weird standing i think
it would satisfy a lot of people to get
him back and to get some love put on
that movie's name and i mean they never
even brought back emil blonsky you know
or lastly they could be working for leap
frog which hey is a stretch but it would
be fun to see a more rich version of
leapfrog trying to make up for what his
dad couldn't and he has his own team of
goons the episode closes yanaka sees the
power i love this song this is the first
piece of new material since 2019 and
they even said in an interview we want
you to get lost in a feeling of strength
and empowerment when listening to this
song and i want that to be completely
true though jen looks defeated in this
last scene looking at her reflection it
feels like the ending of every euphoria
episode i just want this to be the look
of a woman who just recognized yeah
maybe her old life is over but she's a
superhero now verse thinking i can't do
this i don't want to do this i want her
confident i just want her courageous we
get a new courtroom illustration of
blonsky on his release shuttle with his
seven partners happily crying and waving
him off goodbye we get nikki's first
trap with the books in a library to
catch one's attention dennis taking
megan the style what she was doing yeah
that's not actually megan but maybe
roona megan the stallion is jen's latest
client and let me tell you i've never
been happier this is like watching your
two very best different friends meet and
become best friends this is like the
first time you put peanut butter and
chocolate together this is my two
favorite things coming together if they
somehow put anime in this i just explode
and to top it all off they're twerking
they close the episode to body by megan
the stallion and if you told me five
years ago kevin feige would approve of
the hot ebony aka tina snow aka megan
the stallion would be cannon in the mcu
i'd say
are you lying oh that's everything i
spotted in the third episode of she-hulk
follow me on instagram and twitter at
lulu underscore clemens both new
rockstars subscribe to new rockstars for
more breakdowns of everything you love
thanks for watching
it's good you can get a character like
she-hulk when she twerks no one's like
questioning it that's weird but if we
had thor twerk suddenly it's a weird
problem as if thor can't work for some
reason or america's ass imagine people's
outrage at america's ass twerking it up
in front of the entire country i think
it's about damn time our male
superheroes start twerking that's right
whole dance line that is mob they win
the secret wars they just
twerk war
avengers avengers
twerk
[Laughter]
yeah that'll be great
then it's yeah and they get that's the
movie the daniels direct to the ncu
it'll be perfect yeah man all right guys
well she hulk easter eggs the breaking
bad one was worth this whole video alone
was and also for
the pitch for the kind of things shield
should do jessica thank you again for
nailing it you are killing these
she-hulk breakdowns
one million percent you're absolutely
killing it guys subscribe to new
rockstars follow jess clemens lulu
clemens lulu underscore clemens on
twitter we'll see you guys soon
[Music]